y como lo anunciábamos en el primer
invitado directo a América hablaremos
del plebiscito chileno porque la mayoría
de quienes estaban votados a participar
en estos comicios rechazaron la nueva
constitución concretamente el rechazo
obtuvo casi un 62% de los votos como ya
lo mostraba Rosa Pérez más de uno en
revista de prensa aplastando al 38,14%
de la prueba según los datos del
servicio electoral en Chile cuando ya se
habían escrutado el
99,99% de las mesas así eligieron
quedarse con la Constitución vigente de
la época de la dictadura de Augusto
pinochet en lugar de la nueva Carta
Magna redactada por una convención
Constituyente elegida por votación
popular con paridad de género y escaños
reservados para los indígenas que sigue
entonces en chile para analizarlo nos
acompaña desde Santiago Rodrigo España
él Es doctor en ciencia política Rodrigo
Bienvenido a France 24 un placer estar
con usted en el plebiscito de 2020 casi
un 80% de los chilenos afirmaron que
querían un proceso Constituyente pero
aún así se hundió la propuesta de la
nueva Carta Magna A qué se debe entonces
la victoria del rechazo
Hola Buenos días Buenos a varios
factores que están que tienen que ver
con el proceso Constituyente con el
contenido de la carta y también con
aspectos de la campaña en el plebiscito
de salida que era un plebiscito como ya
lo han comentado ustedes un plebiscito
donde era obligatorio votar para todos
los inscritos en el padrón electoral
si uno revisara este proceso
Constituyente uno puede sacar o analizar
cinco aspectos de este de esta situación
o de estos resultados uno tiene que ver
con Cómo
se pueden explicar los resultados otro
de los resultados en sí mismo los
efectos que va a tener para para el
gobierno estos resultados los efectos en
el sistema político y sin lugar a duda
qué va a pasar con el nuevo proceso
Constituyente no sé si quieres que
abordamos algún punto en particular Sí
de hecho quiero que abordemos todos los
puntos Empezando por Cuáles son las
causas de este plebiscito sobre todo en
se ha movido mucha desinformación o se
movió mucha desinformación en torno a la
votación Cuál fue el papel de los datos
en estas elecciones
Mira yo creo que
los resultados se pueden explicar por
situaciones políticas pero también por
temas de gestión de las campañas y
cuando hablamos de situación política yo
creo que tienen que ver primero que nada
con la imagen que tuvo el proceso
Constituyente y en particular con la
imagen que generó la población los
convencionales
los convencionales que se supone que
venían que eran en su gran mayoría de
sectores independientes que estaban muy
asociados con
sectores que eran bastante
contrarios a la clase política
tradicional y donde se generaron una
serie de situaciones que no fueron muy
bien percibidas por la población
entonces hay un problema de imagen del
proceso de los convencionales el segundo
punto sin lugar a duda tiene que ver con
el contenido de la propuesta que hizo la
convención que si bien en su gran
mayoría es un avance significativo para
para para el Estado chileno y para la
sociedad chilena habían ciertas cosas
que eran o demasiado progresistas o de
Avanzada respecto a lo que estaba
acostumbrado a la sociedad chilena Y eso
se puede ver en los resultados eso es
respecto de el proceso Constituyente y
de la convención constitucional ahora
Hay ciertos errores políticos a mi
juicio que tienen que ver con con que
tuvieron impactos sobre los resultados y
eso tiene que ver uno que en el lectivo
en el excesivo protagonismo del gobierno
y de la identificación del gobierno con
el proceso Constituyente y con la opción
apruebo y eso significó que los
problemas que tenía de gestión política
al gobierno en estos seis meses se
identificaron también con el la opción
apruebo y por lo tanto la gente también
castigó de alguna forma a la opción a
prueba Sí y quiero que profundicemos en
un punto que usted mencionó y fueron
estas polémicas propuestas que incluía
la Constituyente por ejemplo hablar de
la plurinacionalidad en la que se
reconocía a las diferentes naciones
indígenas de chile o si hablaba también
de una justicia especial indígena y
también del derecho al aborto
explíquenos por qué estas propuestas
generaron tanta polémica en Chile
a ver lo que pasa es que nosotros en
Chile tenemos un conflicto con nuestros
pueblos originarios y en particular con
el pueblo mapuche y que es un conflicto
que se arrastra hace bastantes años casi
200 años por decirlo de alguna manera y
tiene que ver con qué el estado chileno
no ha hecho un reconocimiento
significativo respecto de este pueblo
originario y ese conflicto que se da en
una zona del sur de chile que abarca hoy
en día Ya dos regiones que la división
política administrativa que tiene el
país dos y a tres regiones ya a esta
altura
genera un efecto una percepción a la
población de
falta de control por parte del Estado en
esa zona
existe a mi juicio un sentimiento
mayoritario de que tiene que haber un
cierto reconocimiento a los pueblos
originarios pero lo que estaba plasmando
o lo que se estaba
señalando la Constitución era ir un poco
más allá y eso a la gente no le hizo
mucho sentido de hecho de las regiones
donde se generan estos conflictos el
rechazo fue muy alto
cercano al 70% Y eso indica que la gente
que vive en esas regiones no estaba de
acuerdo con con lo que señalaba la
Constitución Sí y quiero hacer la
pregunta que creo que toda América
Latina se está haciendo Y es que sigue
ahora porque el presidente de chileno
Gabriel borich dijo que él continuará el
proceso Constituyente sin embargo como
usted lo dice la victoria del rechazo
fue contundente que sigue entonces ahora
en Chile
Mira yo creo que el proceso
Constituyente Va a continuar ahí el 80%
de los votantes en el plebiscito del
2020 estuvieron por un nuevo proceso
Constituyente eso no está en cuestión no
está en cuestión de que tiene que haber
una nueva constitución no está en
cuestión ni por los actores políticos ni
por el conjunto de la ciudadanía la
derecha que se supone defendía en algún
momento la constitución del 80 Está
también movilizada por una nueva
constitución y por lo tanto yo creo que
va a haber una un nuevo proceso
Constituyente ahora la discusión es cómo
va a ser ese nuevo proceso Constituyente
Ya se está consolidando el consenso de
que no debiera haber un nuevo plebiscito
de entradas sino que directamente
pasaríamos a elegir a los nuevos
convencionales y la discusión viene en
el mecanismo para elegir a estos nuevos
convencionales Si va se va a permitir el
mismo sistema respecto de incorporar a
los independientes en en una misma lista
si se le va a dar el mismo grado de
representación a los pueblos originarios
y lo que no está en discusión
Aparentemente es que vamos a seguir con
la regla de tener una convencional
paritaria y eso ya es un tremendo avance
respecto de lo que tiene lo que tenemos
actualmente en el sistema electoral
chileno y muy brevemente ustedes
mencionado a que probablemente una de
las fallas de este plebiscito fue El
excesivo protagonismo del gobierno de
Gabriel borich Cómo se tiene que
reinventar entonces este político y
sobre todo la izquierda chilena que
respaldaba la prueba
hacer un comentario primero que nada el
discurso que dio ayer nuestro presidente
Gabriel borich fue claro y contundente y
lo colocó y lo situó también en una
perspectiva de estadista Él entiende que
hay que hacer cambios en una posición
bastante autocrítica A diferencia de
varios personeros de gobierno y de la
gente que apoyaba en la prueba y por lo
tanto eso lo deja bien posicionado para
a la hora de sentarse a conversar con
todos los actores relevantes segundo Es
evidente que tiene que hacer un ajuste
de
gobierno y ese ajuste de gobierno pasa
por entre otras cambiar al Ministerio
del interior en este caso la ministra
sitges y también sin lugar a duda
cambiar como interlocutor con el
parlamento al ministro Jackson que ha
recibido por tremendas críticas a lo
largo de este momento por lo tanto yo
creo que va a haber un cambio de
gabinete eso le va a dar un nuevo un
nuevo tono al gobierno y bueno y el
gobierno tiene que empezar a hacer
gestión política y trabajar en su
programa de gobierno que estuvo entre
entre paréntesis o en standby hasta este
resultado por lo tanto yo creo que en
esta semana tendremos un cambio de
gabinete tendremos un cambio de tono y
aquí como dijo el presidente el
parlamento va a jugar un rol